ناشدت جمهورية دونباس الشعبية
أجمل طلب قررت على
إجراء عملية عسكرية خاصة
والغرض من حماية الأشخاص الموجودين
لمدة ثماني سنوات
البلطجة 12
ارفعوا أيديكم وهذا سيكون
السعي وراء
ترمس كتب تجريد جميل
وكذلك تناسب المتوسط ​​بعد الدراسة
العديد من الجرائم الدموية
ضد عظامها ومواطنيها
ينفع الطفل
[موسيقى]
طار
مع رقم واحد في أوكرانيا اليوم في حقيبة
الرئيس بوتين أولوسيس لا يعمل
رسم محفوف بالمخاطر بشكل خاص في دونباس
هنا كل ضرباتي على مخاطرنا
البنية التحتية ثم وفقا للمدعي العام لدينا
لا أحد محاط بالتسليم
[موسيقى]
كان وبالتالي سوف أتحقق بشكل مختلف مع
ستحصل بعد ذلك على الرئيس بايدن
الطوابع في نفس الحرب bachyly 2 ل
بيتر ايم الدولي بالكاد اليوم
سوف تؤخذ تحت الجلد للخدمات
يمكنك الدخول يرتكب في ثقب الباب في المنزل نحن
ضد الجيش الآخر في القطاع
دفاع مفصل لأوكرانيا
للحصول على اختصار معك سأكون قادرًا على الاستئجار
مجلس الوزراء من وزراء أوكرانيا خلف نقابة المحامين ط
مرة أخرى سوف أخرج إلى النجم دون ذعر ، نحن
نحن أقوى من صفوف القرية التي نحن فيها الآن
حسنا ، نحن أوكرانيا المجد لأوكرانيا
[موسيقى]